so we have some pretty interesting news
today last night Marvel started a
countdown clock for Avengers 4 if you go
to Marvel calm and then you click on the
tab that says movies you go to Avengers
untitled click on that then you can see
the clock now if you don't know just by
looking at it this is the countdown
until May 3rd when Avengers 4 comes out
in theaters this is really the first
official thing Marvel has really given
us about Avengers 4 but it's funny
because they're not really giving us
much here all they're really doing is
giving us a official release date for
Avengers 4 to hit theaters there was
some talk a while back about them
changing the date maybe an early release
date but this clearly tells us that it
comes out May 3rd of 2019 a lot of
people are really starting to look into
this scene if it means more than just a
countdown until the movie comes out I
wouldn't put it past Kevin Feige or the
Russo brothers but I don't think that's
what this is Marvel has been pretty
tight lid on everything concerning of
interest for it we don't even have the
title yet as I mentioned if you go to
Marvel calm it says Avengers untitled it
doesn't even give us the title yet but
this is all strategic this is all
strategy that Marvel is doing this
countdown clock it's a strategy Kevin
Feige saying that we're going to get the
trailer before the end of the year
strategy all these actors giving us fake
spoilers for the movie it's all just
strategy used by Marvel right now all of
them marketing for Avengers 4 is pretty
much done by the fans this is sort of
their first official publicity stunt for
Avengers 4 this isn't a leak coming out
somewhere and the fans blowing it up
this is actually directly from Marvel
and this is great news because the
trailer is supposed to come out this
month but Marvel hasn't actually said
anything official on it but now we're
seeing movement from them and this is
most likely in preparation for the
trailer coming out so the official
countdown to Avengers 4 has begun we
could probably expect to get the title
and the first teaser trailer this month
the hype is getting real let me know how
excited you are to see that first
trailer for Avengers 4 and let me know
if you think that this countdown
actually means anything and my giveaway
still continues I'm given a
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool - and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]